This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When I've done this, I've filled this out. I'll leave it on the door so that the owner is aware of the fact that we made a visit. And that they need to take care of the lawn. They may not even be aware of the fact that the city of Gainesville has an ordinance that prohibits excessive growth. In communities across America, lawns that are brown or overgrown are considered especially heinous. Elite squads of dedicated individuals have been deputized by their local governments or home owners associations to take action against those whose lawns fail to meet community standards.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。当我做完这些时，我已经填好了这个表格。我会把它留在门上，好让业主知道我们来拜访过。而且他们需要处理一下草坪。他们甚至可能不知道盖恩斯维尔（Gainesville）市有一项禁止草坪过度生长的法令。在全美各地的社区中，呈棕色或杂草丛生的草坪被认为尤为十恶不赦。地方政府或业主协会（HOA）已经授权了一支由热心人士组成的精锐小队，对那些草坪不符合社区标准的行为采取行动。
Call them lawn enforcement agents. Producer Sam Greenspan. This is his story. In 2008, a Lawn Enforcement agent stopped by a home in Hudson, Florida outside of Tampa. Maybe the agent snapped some photos, maybe there were some boxes ticked off a checklist. Whatever the agent's field methods, he or she went back to law enforcement HQ and sent out a letter. They sent out letters stating that, you know, you're a law enforcement, you have a lot
姑且称他们为草坪执法人员吧。制作人萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）。这是他的故事。2008年，一名草坪执法人员来到坦帕（Tampa）郊外佛罗里达州哈德逊（Hudson）的一处住宅。也许这位执法人员拍了几张照片，也许在检查清单上勾选了几个方框。无论该执法人员的实地方法如何，他或她回到了执法总部并发出一封信。他们发出的信件内容大致是，你知道的，你是一个执法，你有很多
of bear spots, you have a lot of weeds. My sprinkler system was busted and I didn't have the money at that time to repair it. That's Joe Prudente, who with his wife Pat, owns the home in question. Law enforcement thought that the Prudente's lawn was too brown, too weedy, and not well maintained. This was not the first such letter that the Prudente's had received. But Joe Prudente says he is no deadbeat. Over the course of a few years, he had tried to keep a clean, green lawn as best he could.
光秃秃的斑块，你有很多杂草。我的喷灌系统坏了，当时我没有钱修理它。那是乔·普鲁登特（Joe Prudente），他和妻子帕特（Pat）拥有这栋房子。执法部门认为普鲁登特的草坪太棕、杂草太多，维护得不好。这已经不是普鲁登特夫妇收到这样的第一封信了。但乔·普鲁登特说他绝不是个老赖。在过去的几年里，他尽其所能地试图保持草坪清洁、翠绿。
He watered it. He put down grass seeds and grass plucks. He even dug up and completely replanted the grass in his front yard three times over. I've done it three, three times. The first time I had a company do it, it charged me like, you know, $1,200. And I said, I'm not doing this, you know, every time it died. Joe met with his homeowners association, but they were not cutting him any slack. So then finally they did some ruling that if I didn't put sod down the whole place, they'll law firm was sending it to the judge to the court. And see what would happen was so good, you know, were they going to lock me up? Then I
他给草坪浇水。他撒下草籽和草皮块。甚至把前院的草全部挖出来，重新种植了整整三次。我已经做过三次，三次了。第一次我找了一家公司来做，花了我大概，你知道的，1,200美元。我说，每次草死掉我都这么搞的话，我可吃不消。乔会见了他们的业主协会，但他们一点情面也不讲。所以最后他们下达了一项裁决，如果我不把整个地方铺上草皮，律师事务所就会把案子提交给法官、提交给法庭。看看结果会怎么样，你知道的，难道他们要把我关起来吗？然后我
got to put me in jail for not putting grass down. I said, that's crazy. Shortly thereafter, Joe got another letter. It was a court order to turn myself in or get arrested. I didn't want everybody to see police coming to the house. Caught me away for, they probably go, oh, look at this guy, he's probably robbed the bank, you know, how neighbors are. So I did it the quiet way.
得因为没铺草皮而被关进监狱吗？我说，这太疯狂了。不久之后，乔又收到了一封信。那是一份要求我自首否则就会被逮捕的法院传票。我不想让所有人都看到警察来到家里。这会让我很难堪，他们可能会想，瞧这家伙，他大概抢了银行吧，你知道邻居们都是怎么想的。所以我用了安静的方式。
I turned myself in. At 66 years old, Joe Prudente, So I did it the quiet way. I turned myself in. At 66 years old Joe Prudente, an otherwise law abiding retiree from Long Island, presented himself to the Pasco County jail wearing a grandpa gone wild t-shirt. He was apprehended on allegations of failing to properly maintain his lawn to community standards. There was no bail. No bail until the side was done. Now fortunately for Joe, the local paper had written about the arrest and detainment of a senior citizen for having a brown lawn. Word got around and dozens of people came to help dig up and re-saw the Pradente's lawn.
我自首了。66岁高龄的乔·普鲁登特，所以我用了一种安静的方式。我自首了。66岁高龄的乔·普鲁登特，这位来自长岛、一向奉公守法的退休人员，穿着一件“疯狂老头”（grandpa gone wild）的T恤出现在帕斯科县（Pasco County）监狱。他因未能妥善维护草坪以符合社区标准而被捕。没有保释。在草坪弄好之前不得保释。对乔来说幸运的是，当地报纸报道了一位老年人因草坪变黄而被捕和拘留的事情。消息传开了，几十个人赶来帮忙挖掘并重新为普鲁登特家的草坪铺上草皮。
Joe was released from jail the next day. Most cases of homeowners brushing up against lawn enforcement do not end in jail time. But Joe Prudente was not the only person to have ended up behind bars because of a landscaping issue. Frank Yose of Grand Prairie, Texas did two days in jail for having an overgrown lawn. And Gary Settle, a 75-year-old former city council member of Rizel Texas, had a warrant issued for her arrest until some neighborhood kids came by and mowed the lawn that she had been unable to take care of on her own. There's a paradox to the lawn. On the one hand, it is the pedestal on which sits the greatest symbol of the American dream,
乔第二天就被释放出狱了。大多数业主与草坪执法人员发生摩擦的案件并没有以入狱告终。但乔·普鲁登特并不是唯一一个因景观美化问题而锒铛入狱的人。德克萨斯州大草原城（Grand Prairie）的弗兰克·约瑟（Frank Yose）因草坪杂草丛生而在监狱里呆了两天。得克萨斯州雷泽尔（Rizel）75岁的前市议会议员加里·塞特尔（Gary Settle）也曾被发出逮捕令，直到一些邻近的孩子顺道过来帮她修剪了她无力自行打理的草坪。草坪其实包含着一个悖论。一方面，它是承载美国梦伟大象征的基座，
the home. And homeowners are independent and free, and have domain over their own little corner of the American dream, the home. And homeowners are independent and free, and have domain over their own little corner of the world. And yet, and yet, the lawn is the least free will-controlled landscape insofar as people are constantly pressured, either by formal or informal institutions, into managing it just like their neighbors. That's Paul Robbins, director of the Nelson Institute for Environmental Studies at the University
也就是家。而房主是独立且自由的，对美国梦中他们自己的那一小方天地拥有主权，也就是家。房主是独立自由的，对他们自己的世界里那一小方天地拥有主权。然而，然而，草坪却是最不具自由意志控制的景观，因为人们不断受到来自正式或非正式机构的压力，被迫像他们的邻居一样去管理它。威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校纳尔逊环境研究所所长保罗·罗宾斯（Paul Robbins）如是说。
of Wisconsin and Madison. And the author of the book, Lawn People, how grasses, weeds, and chemicals make us who we are. Grass may be a plant, but a lawn is a designed object. A lawn is an entirely designed object, that kind of imaginary nice clean green lawn. That's an entirely engineered landscape. And the reason we maintain this landscape, says Paul Robbins, is about everything except the grass. It's about everything else. It's about community. It's about proper moral behavior.
他也是《草坪人：草、杂草和化学品如何塑造了我们》（Lawn People: How Grasses, Weeds, and Chemicals Make Us Who We Are）一书的作者。草可能是一种植物，但草坪是一个精心设计的人造物。草坪是一个完全设计好的人造物，那种想象中美好、干净、翠绿的草坪。那完全是一个经过人工精心改造的景观。保罗·罗宾斯说，我们维护这种景观的原因，除了草本身，其实关乎一切。它关乎其他所有事情。它关乎社区。它关乎正确的道德行为。
It's about participating in the life of a community. Even in the beginning, lawns were always about something else. The lawn, or really the idea of lawns, began with art. The Italians, for a while, were painting these sort of pastoral scenes, scenes full of grasslands and hedges. Grasslands and hedges that didn't actually exist. No, I mean, these are pastoral images out of somebody's imagination of what the landscape should look like.
它关乎参与社区生活。即使在最初，草坪也总是关乎其他事情。草坪，或者说草坪的理念，始于艺术。有一段时间，意大利人一直在画这种田园风光，画中充满了草原和树篱。那些实际上并不存在的草原和树篱。不，我的意思是，这些都是田园诗般的图像，来自于某些人对景观应该是什么样子的想象。
And these paintings got popular among Great Britain's landed elite. They liked the paintings so much that they wanted to live in them. What the British were doing is designing their landscapes to look like what was trending in Italian painting. So life definitely followed art, in this case. A style of English garden developed where a prominent feature is a green lawn. And right away, everyone recognized that these soft, verdant grasses
这些画在大英帝国的土地精英中流行起来。他们太喜欢这些画了，以至于他们想生活在画里。英国人当时在做的是设计他们的景观，使其看起来像是意大利绘画中的流行趋势。所以在这种情况下，生活确实模仿了艺术。一种英国花园风格发展起来，其显著特征就是绿草坪。而且每个人立刻都认识到，这些柔软、翠绿的草
were more than just a nice place to walk around barefoot outside. Elon was about power. Elon was a way for these English elites to show off. They were so wealthy that they didn't need this land to grow food. They could afford to let their fields go fallow. And could afford to keep grazing animals and sith-wielding peasants to keep it short.
不仅仅是一个赤脚在户外走走的好地方。草坪关乎权力。草坪是这些英国精英炫耀的一种方式。他们是如此富有，以至于他们不需要这片土地来种植粮食。他们有能力让土地荒芜。也有能力养得起放牧的动物和挥舞着镰刀的农民来保持草坪的短小。
When European colonists set sail for the new world, they took grasses with them. But lawns were still mostly for rich people and eventually public parks. It wasn't until the turn of the 20th century, with the first suburbs that lawn started appearing around the homes of the middle class. And here is where the lawn shifts from being about the flagrant display of wealth to a moral force for the good of civilization. Andrew Jackson Downing, considered by some to be the father of American landscape architecture, who is slightly older than the other guy considered to be the father of American landscape architecture, Frederick Law Olmsted. I know you're thinking it nerds.
当欧洲殖民者起航前往新世界时，他们把草种带了过去。但草坪大多仍然属于富人，最终成为公共公园。直到20世纪初，随着第一批郊区的出现，草坪才开始在中产阶级的家门前出现。正是在这里，草坪的作用从炫耀财富的招摇过市，转变为促进文明福祉的道德力量。安德鲁·杰克逊·唐宁（Andrew Jackson Downing），被某些人视为美国景观建筑之父，他比被视为美国景观建筑之父的另一个人稍年长一些，那就是弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德（Frederick Law Olmsted）。我知道你们这些书呆子心里在想什么。
Downing wrote in 1850, quote, When smiling lawns and tasteful cottages begin to embellish a country, we know that order and culture are established. There was kind of a social message, which is that if you make it look like this, we will make better citizens. As opposed to right having living in squalor and the urban areas are considered evil and myasmic and problematic. A well-maintained law, in other words, is the opposite of a broken window. Exactly. It's precisely that. Most people think whatever is going on outside the house, if it's civilized, manicured and well-maintained, Most people think whatever's going on outside the house, if it's civilized, manicured, and well maintained, reflects something that's going on good inside the house. With the start of the Great American Suburbanization in the 1950s, suddenly middle-class people were owning larger and larger swathes of land.
唐宁在1850年写道，引述：“当微笑的草坪和雅致的乡村小屋开始点缀一个国家时，我们就知道秩序和文化已经建立。”这其中有一种社会信息，那就是如果你把它弄成这样，我们就会造就更好的公民。而不是生活在污秽之中，城市地区被视为邪恶、充满瘴气和问题的。换句话说，维护良好的草坪就是破窗效应的反面。没错。正是如此。大多数人认为，无论房子外面发生什么，如果它是文明的、修剪整齐的和维护良好的，大多数人认为，无论房子外面发生什么，如果它是文明的、修剪整齐和维护良好的，就反映了房子内部正在发生好的事情。随着20世纪50年代美国大郊区化运动的开始，中产阶级突然拥有了越来越大面积的土地。
So covering it with grass was partly utilitarian. You know, you have this big piece of land. You gotta do something with it. But this connection between lawn and order only grew stronger and our lawns got bigger. We did an air photography study and you tax assessor's data for Franklin County, which is Columbus, Ohio. So it's a very typical American city. And we found that about 25% of the entire county
因此用草覆盖它在一定程度上是出于功利主义。你知道的，你有这么大一块地。你总得拿它做点什么。但草坪与秩序之间的这种联系变得越来越强，我们的草坪也越来越大。我们对富兰克林县（Franklin County）进行了航空摄影研究和税务评估员数据分析，富兰克林县就是俄亥俄州哥伦布市。所以这是一个非常典型的美国城市。我们发现整个县大约25%的面积
was turf grass lawns. That doesn't include football fields. It doesn't include golf courses. 25% A quarter of the entire city of Columbus is lawns. Grass living a completely unnatural life cycle. We don't like grass grow tall enough to go to seed, but we also water and fertilize it
都是草皮草坪。这不包括足球场。不包括高尔夫球场。25%！整个哥伦布市四分之一的面积都是草坪。这些草过着完全不自然的生命周期。我们不喜欢草长得太高而结籽，但我们也给它浇水和施肥
to keep it from going dormant. We don't let it die, but we also don't let it reproduce. The author Michael Pollan wrote that lawns are nature purged of sex and death. Feed, weed, cut, repeat. Paul Robbins interviewed dozens of people about their lawns for his book. People told him that if their grass got too long, neighbors would come by and ask if their lawnmower
以防止它进入休眠状态。我们不让它死掉，但我们也不让它繁殖。作家迈克尔·波伦（Michael Pollan）写道，草坪是剥离了性和死亡的大自然。喂养、除草、修剪、重复。保罗·罗宾斯就草坪问题采访了数十人并写进了他的书中。人们告诉他，如果他们的草长得太长，邻居们就会过来问他们的割草机
was broken, if they needed a borrow one. People who wouldn't move their lawn might find an aggressive neighbor had done it for them in the middle of the night or while they were out of town. Youmo, because everybody else does. The free market, American free neoliberal subject who had does as he or she pleases
是不是坏了，是否需要借一个。那些不割草的人可能会发现，某个激进的邻居在半夜或他们不在城里时已经帮他们割好了。你得割草，因为其他人都在这么做。自由市场、美国自由新自由主义的主体，那些随心所欲的人
would just say to hell with my neighbors, I'm just gonna let my lawn grow. But instead they do the communist thing, right? Which is collective management of what is essentially immoral commons. Like it's not your lawn. It's the whole community's lawn and irresponsible for this part. Deviate from acceptable community norms, and your community goes to war with you. Which is how you get cases like Joe Prudente being thrown in jail for failing to keep
本可以对邻居说见鬼去吧，我偏要让我的草长高。但相反，他们做了集体主义的事情，对吧？也就是对本质上属于非道德公共资源的东西进行集体管理。这不像它是你的草坪。这是整个社区的草坪，对这部分不负责任是不行的。偏离可接受的社区规范，你的社区就会向你宣战。这就是为什么会出现像乔·普鲁登特这样因为未能保持草坪符合所谓的社区标准而被扔进监狱的案例。
his lawn up to quote unquote community standards. One of the guys in my say says, what are you here for, Grandpa? in jail for failing to keep his lawn up to quote unquote community standards. One of the guys in my seat says, what are you here for, Grandpa? I said, grass. He said, smoke in it or sell in it. But as much as the lawn seems to be rooted to the American landscape, we may be seen a transition, at least here out west. We're in an historic drought, and that demands unprecedented action.
我同牢房的一个家伙问我：“你是因为什么进来的，老头？”因为未能保持草坪符合所谓的社区标准而被扔进监狱。我同牢房的一个家伙问我：“你是因为什么进来的，老头？”我说，因为草。他说，抽的还是卖的？但尽管草坪似乎深深植根于美国景观，我们可能正在见证一场转变，至少在我们这里的西部是这样。我们正处于一场历史性的干旱中，这需要采取前所未有的行动。
It's for that reason that I'm issuing an executive order, mandating substantial water reduction across our state. California Governor Jerry Brown declared in 2015 that our state would need to cut water use by 25%. We're in a new era. The idea of your nicely-green grass, getting lots of water every day. use by 25%. Here in California, the lawn is perhaps the most visible symbol of the drought. Water restrictions allow people to water only 2 or 3 times a week, down from 4 or 5 or
正因如此，我正在发布一项行政命令，强制全州大幅削减用水量。加利福尼亚州州长杰里·布朗（Jerry Brown）在2015年宣布，我们州需要将用水量减少25%。我们进入了一个新时代。你那翠绿的草坪每天都要浇很多水的想法。用水量减少25%。在这里，加利福尼亚州，草坪也许是这场干旱最显眼的象征。限水令允许人们每周只浇水2到3次，比以前的4到5次
even more. In California, Arizona, Nevada, governments are actually paying people to rip out their grass. Prices range from $1 to as much as $4 per square foot of turf removed, which homeowners could then use to buy artificial turf or use it for zero escaping, which is landscaping with things that don't need water like rocks. Some people are also choosing to put native plants in their yards, which theoretically should grow with rain water only, and would help restore the ecosystem
甚至更多有所减少。在加利福尼亚州、亚利桑那州和内华达州，政府实际上正在花钱让人拔掉草坪。价格从每移除一平方英尺草皮1美元到4美元不等，房主随后可以用这些钱购买人造草坪，或者用于沙漠景观美化（xeriscaping），也就是用不需要水的岩石之类东西来做景观设计。有些人还选择在院子里种植本土植物，理论上这些植物只需雨水就能生长，并将有助于恢复
that had been there before. Or you can just let your long go brown. California has a bunch of public service announcements that are all like, Get down with brown. We'll get through this rock just fine. Even our lawns. Join the movements and help fight the drought.
原本在那里的生态系统。或者你也可以让你的草坪变成棕色。加利福尼亚州有一系列公益广告，主题都是“接受棕色草坪吧”。我们能安然度过这场干旱。连我们的草坪也能。加入这个运动，帮助抗击干旱。
Get down with brown. Brown is the new green. Do your part to help California fight the drought. Nobody bought a home in this country to have a brown lawn. This is America. We have green grass for a reason here. That's the American dream is to have a green lawn. So invest a little bit in our service,
接受棕色草坪吧。棕色是新的绿色。尽你的一份力量帮助加州抗击干旱。在这个国家，没有人买房是为了拥抱一片棕色的草坪。这里是美国。我们这里有绿草是有原因的。这就是美国梦——拥园中绿草。所以在我们的服务上投资一点，
and you can have a green lawn during invest a little bit in our service and you can have a green lawn during that drought season. This is David Bartlett of Extreme Greengrass. He is decidedly not down with brown. I'm David Bartlett with Extreme Greengrass and we are turning her brown grass green. And he's doing this by literally painting a customer's lawn green. We are spraying on an all natural,
你就能在干旱季节拥有一片绿草坪。在我们的服务上投资一点，你就能在干旱季节拥有一片绿草坪。这是Extreme Greengrass公司的大卫·巴特利特（David Bartlett）。他坚决不接受棕色草坪。我是Extreme Greengrass的大卫·巴特利特，我们正在把枯黄的草变绿。他是怎么做到的呢？字面意思，给客户的草坪刷绿漆。我们正在喷洒一种纯天然、
earth-friendly product that we manufacture called extreme green grass. Last three to six months. When we got there, the customer's grass was golden brown. It had been watered in six months. David uses a spray wand attached to a tank full of a liquid, which he swears as non-toxic. And as he's spraying, it's like magic,
环保的产品，由我们自己制造，名为“极致绿草”（extreme green grass）。可持续三到六个月。当我们到达那里时，客户的草是金黄色的。它已经有六个月没浇过水了。大卫使用的是连接到一个装满液体的罐子上的喷枪，他发誓这是无毒的。当他喷洒时，就像变魔术一样，
like he's transforming a wheat field into a soccer pitch. Except the grass is still crunchy. Yeah, the crunchiness doesn't change. Unfortunately, if I could change that process, I'd be rich. You do anything besides the green? Yeah, we do white, that Christmas season. Maybe it looks like you got a snowy yard, kind of looks like you went up and got some snow from the mountains.
就像他把一片麦田变成了足球场。除了草摸起来依然脆脆的。是的，这种脆脆的触感不会改变。不幸的是，如果我能改变这个过程，我早就发财了。除了绿色，你们还做别的颜色吗？是的，我们在圣诞节期间做白色的。也许看起来你的院子下雪了，有点像你上山去弄了些雪回来。
Yeah, any like, pank or purple orange? Pank, I'll do that for you, bro. David got into this line of work after a friend got him a similar service for his lawn as a gift. David had been working in landscaping and thought he could do a better job than the other companies he had seen. Lawn painting is actually not new, but if you've never heard of it, it's because it's generally only been used on golf courses and pro sports fields. It's only since this most recent drought that lawn painting has come home. When I first heard about lawn painting, I had assumed it would be scoffed at by the lawn
是的，有什么粉色、紫色、橙色吗？粉色？我可以为你做这个，兄弟。大卫涉足这一行是因为一个朋友送给他类似的服务作为他草坪的礼物。大卫以前一直从事园林绿化工作，他认为自己能比他见过的其他公司做得更好。草坪喷漆其实并不是什么新鲜事，但如果你从未听说过它，那是因为它通常只用在髙尔夫球场和职业运动场上。直到最近这次干旱，草坪喷漆才真正走入寻常百姓家。当我第一次听说草坪喷漆时，我曾以为它会被草坪狂热者嗤之以鼻，
obsessives, the kind of people who had Joe Pardente thrown in jail. But a lot of extreme green grasses clients are homeowners associations. Lawn painting is becoming accepted by even the strictest lawn enforcement agencies. It kind of makes you wonder if we as a society are beginning to question the supremacy of the perfectly kept lawn, maybe we can finally quit lawn shaming each other. This is America, we can always find ways to shame each other. I think it's very, very interesting to see what's happening in California with people
也就是那种把乔·普鲁登特送进监狱的人。但Extreme Greengrass的许多客户其实是业主协会。草坪喷漆甚至开始被最严格的草坪执法机构所接受。这不禁让人怀疑，作为社会的我们是否开始质疑完美修剪草坪的至高无上地位，也许我们终于可以停止互相进行草坪羞辱了。这里是美国，我们总能找到方法互相羞辱。我觉得非常非常有趣的是，看到加利福尼亚州发生的事情，人们
getting on each other's case for having green grass. After all these decades of getting on each other's case for not having green grass, that's Paul Robbins again. Now we have a case where the drought has inspired people to really whack one another on the internet or whatever else sort of shame people for putting water on their lawn. See Twitter hashtag droughtshaming. Paul says it's good that people are looking to conserve water, but the moral architecture of drought-chaming is a little too familiar. It's just the newest trend on how people police each other's lawns. It's just another version of the same thing. Like moral outrage that people are not
因为别人拥有绿草而对他们评头论足。在经历了这几十年来因为别人没有绿草而对他们评头论足之后——这又是保罗·罗宾斯说的。现在我们遇到这样一种情况，干旱激发了人们真正在互联网或其他地方互相抨击，或者因给草坪浇水而羞辱他人。参见推特话题标签#干旱羞辱（#droughtshaming）。保罗说，人们寻求节约用水是件好事，但干旱羞辱的道德架构却似曾相识。这只是人们如何监管彼此草坪的最新趋势。这只是同一事物的又一个版本。就像人们没有
doing their share is sort of a natural response to people's land management, just like it was for keeping a lawn green. And so if David Bartlett does his job too well, makes lawns look too much like they get tons of water, his customers might get drought-shamed by people who have gotten a little too down with brown. As they say, the grass is always greener, even when it's browner. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Greenspan With Katie Mingle, Avery Trollfum and me Roman Mars Thank you to Isaac Brown and Eric Flagg, Directors of the Film, Gimme Green. That's where the tape of the law enforcement agent that you heard at the beginning of this story originally
尽到自己责任时的道德愤怒，某种程度上是对人们土地管理的一种自然反应，就像当年保持草坪翠绿时一样。所以，如果大卫·巴特利特的工作做得太好，让草坪看起来像是得到了大量的水，他的客户可能会被那些对棕色草坪适应得很好的人进行“干旱羞辱”。俗话说，邻家的草总是更绿，哪怕它其实是棕色的。本周的 99% Invisible 由萨姆·格林斯潘与凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特罗尔芬（Avery Trollfum）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。感谢电影《绿化美国》（Gimme Green）的导演艾萨克·布朗（Isaac Brown）和埃里克·弗莱格（Eric Flagg）。这正是你在本故事开头听到的执法人员录音的出处，
appeared will have a link to the film on our website. Thanks also to Devin Brown, Robert Vogelsen, Brent Green, Sharon Hall, Braden K, Kelly Larson, Molly Peterson, Terence Smith, and Kelly Turner. We are a project of 91.7K ALWU San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign. An architecture and interior firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but you can listen to every single
我们将在网站上提供该电影的链接。同样感谢德文·布朗（Devin Brown）、罗伯特·福格尔森（Robert Vogelsen）、布伦特·格林（Brent Green）、莎伦·霍尔（Sharon Hall）、布赖登·K（Braden K）、凯利·拉森（Kelly Larson）、莫莉·彼得森（Molly Peterson）、特伦斯·史密斯（Terence Smith）和凯利·特纳（Kelly Turner）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个节目，由 ArcSign 的办公室制作。ArcSign 是一家建筑与室内设计公司。位于美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。我们在 Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram 和 Spotify 上都有账号，但你可以在 99pi.org 上收听 99% Invisible 的每一期节目，
episode of 99% Invisible and we have pictures and lots of other stuff there too at 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里还有图片以及大量其他内容。嗯。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。